hey leute herzlich willkommen zur
finalen folge von minecraft also nee
traurig traurig luca ein letztes mal
schlafen gehen genießen wir nochmal den
wunderschönen anblick aus unserem
schlafzimmer ist schon traumhaft schön
gewesen muss ich sagen ab in die kiste
mit uns vor allem wenn ich so daran
denke dass wir in der ersten folge
einfach gar nicht gepennt haben dann
haben wir irgendwie in seinem halben
höhleneingang gepennt es ist schon schön
aber das ganze wird natürlich auch ein
schönes ende haben denn wir gehen in das
ende ja genau das machen wir leute und
dafür müssen wir es leider mal in den
game mode ihr habt schon gesehen ich
habe mir ein ende auge gegeben
luca du fliegst mir jetzt einfach mal
hinterher ja ja wir müssen leider in den
game mode einfach um zu sehen wo das
stronghold ist und deswegen haben wir
auch heute keine challenge weil die
challenge wird es quasi seinen ender
drachen zu töten
bist du noch da du bist gerade direkt
abgebrochen sorry ja wo bist du denn du
kannst dich ja gleich einfach zu
montieren wenn ich da wieder was ich
sagen wollte ist dass wir heute keine
challenge haben weil die challenge quasi
es sein wird dass wir den ender drachen
versuchen zu töten ja genau so ist es
und ich denke mal das ist auch challenge
genug ender drachen töten ist jetzt
nicht so dass leichteste wie man als
erfahrener minecraft spieler wie wir es
sind weiß genau da vorne ging es runter
ich haben gerade eben schon mal geguckt
wo es ist ich wollte mich ein kind
reportieren aber leider sind die command
blöcke aus und so zac hier geht's runter
luca einmal runter hier runter und zack
wir sind da meine damen und herren mögen
themen im raum der uns ins ende führt ok
game 80 leute das ende von minecraft
maut ich platziere nun das auge hier
rein wenn wir pech haben am geht es dass
man keine plattform unter sich hat wenn
man jetzt wo mein gott walther schwede
stefan böcher gestorben ja das war so
bitter gewesen ist wäre so bitter
gewesen
also erstmal da der silberfisch der
blöde pizza okay jetzt wird aber
sicherheitshalber zu bauen
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das paar
teils nur funktioniert doch ok
irgendwann noch ein springen ja 321
immer wieder auf gott und gott ok
vorsicht einen baum bevor der rache
kommt ja ich hab den blogger weggeworfen
ich habe nur gesehen wie du die drei
blöcke weg geworfen was machen wir jetzt
ja wir müssen auf die plattform gehen
ich habe 53 blöcke reicht das ja das
reicht auf jeden fall okay ich war schon
mal rüber
ich habe nur 15 pfeile ich habe immer
wieder ja wir können uns ja auch so ich
hab ich hab noch ein bisschen brauchen
25 feier in dem hotel auf dem bogen wir
müssen jetzt richtig gut schießen wir
müssen jetzt oben beim ende brachen
diese dinger wegschießen
damit er nicht mehr damit er sich nicht
mehr regenerieren kann ja und wir müssen
richtig gut zielen einfach wie du weißt
nicht mehr also nicht mehr allzu viele
pfeile haben
das ist einfach produkt müssen uns da
hoch bauen und die teile zerstören
einfach ja das ist so ätzend also das
ist echt das schlimmste was man machen
kann eigentlich man ja ich freue mich
jetzt auch hoch damit ich einfach bei
den kleinen bau ich mich auf jeden fall
auch damit ich gleich vielleicht noch
ein bisschen weiter habe um den drachen
abzuschießen
ja genau abzuschießen okay allerdings
mit ihnen ja übel wenn man die
zerschlägt ja ja klar vorsicht aber die
kleinen kannst du eigentlich auch ganz
gut mit einem pfeil erwischen ja es ist
sollte irgendwie machbar sein also auf
jeden fall nicht die ender männer
anschauen weißt du ja und so zum
erwischt den
ok hab ich erwischt hat er schon
aussieht will dass die ganze boxen hier
das ist schon längst aus mein gott bin
ich ein profi okay gut also wird's
erstellt ist quasi gerade die teile der
flotte nicht angegriffen alter schwede
wo ich war grad dreht mega konzentriert
dass ich die die leucht dinger treffe
seid die leucht dinge leute das ist
einfach minecraft mit profis ist es
nicht irgendwie normales minecraft ok oh
da wird ja auch entschieden
ich nehme da ganz oben
das habe ich dann auch schon probiert
habe ich ende vorsicht gott nicht
sterben jetzt okay ganz oben habe ich
wie viele brauchen wir dann noch wo ist
da noch überall eins drauf der typ sich
wenn er ende brachte sich was holen will
ja genau wenn er wenn er regeneriert ich
hoffe mal kannst du mal ganz kurz gucken
aber zu mir fliegt okay da ganz hinten
da oben ist auch eins drauf ich brauche
mich dann einfach hoch ja ich freue mich
auch gerade hoch zu welchen ich hoffe
mal dass hier überhaupt noch welche sind
okay sind gar keine mehr
hey leute das ist so lächerlich wie wir
das hier gerade machen
jeder der in wien cent geht mit einer
diamant rüstung diamant schwertern und
keine ahnung was und wie man das mit
solchen [ __ ] sachen hier
es ist glaube ich auch dass es auch
eigentlich dafür dass es so minecraft
ende ist und so viel ich das gar nicht
so krass schwierig oder warten wir mal
ab bis wir richtig gegen den drachen
kämpfen und ich glaube das wird schon
hart es wird schon richtig hart also
alte euro er hat mich das war grad schon
mal richtig fertig okay da oben ist noch
ob ich gerade hoch derzeit nur cool wenn
der drache mich nicht irgendwie tötete
ach so da brat ok ich hab' laden und
anderen getroffen ich werde jetzt mal
nicht da oben auf den dings schießen das
dürfte nicht der letzte sein
gott ich muss mich nur grad irgendwie so
ein bisschen ein bulliger du musst es
unbedingt jetzt schnell zerstören falls
der drache wieder zu dir kommt ich hab's
der stadt ja als sind alle weg jetzt
alle sind weg
alles weg ja alles nur dass wir das
geschafft haben
ja wir haben aber der drache ist noch
nicht zerstört ja das ist ja ist ja nur
da also
unser leichteste übung vor sich um ein
gott max da ist noch alles da drüben da
drüben ist noch 12 na da wo er den faden
zieht dieses fette ding da vorne welches
fette dingen davor nicht sehen nichts
mehr hinter dir auf dem turm hinter dir
also mir ist nichts am nichts echt
nein da war nichts warte mal ich habe
extra rüber geguckt gott luca bitte
überlebe der natürlich überlebe ich bin
schon fast wieder auf dem boden als gut
aber hey gerade eigentlich nicht
eigentlich hab ich alles abgebaut doch
wie ich sehe es noch ich sehe es noch da
hilft ein ganz kleines teil
ok ich probiere es jetzt ist es so
schwer zu treffen ich probier's mal zu
treffen
der drache fliegt davor nemax alles gut
ich brauche mich hoch ich brauch' ich
hoch kümmert euch dann hoffen dass der
drache mich vielleicht nicht direkt
tötet ok ich musste ich der kommt halt
immer wieder zurück das weißt du
hoffentlich ja ja aber dann sag mir
bescheid wenn er kommt ich bin jetzt
oben und schafft dass luca ja ich habe
zweieinhalb herzen drache kommt wo nein
eineinhalb herzen
oh mein gott der drache darf nicht
nochmal kommen ich habe keine scheu mehr
schießen auf den skis auf ihn schießt
auf ihn
mein gott halbes herz schießt den
drachen luca eineinhalb herzen warte ich
regeneriere wieder - und auch ihr auf
ihn ich habe doch keine teile mehr desto
mehr laufen am besten früh genug
bescheid wenn er kommt okay okay okay
okay okay okay du bist gleich wieder da
ich stelle mich vor sich ich beschütze
dich okay ich bin wieder unten
okay wie viel hast du noch sechs gibst
du mir die ich glaube ich kann es
treffen
oh ich habe einmal getroffen sehr gut
gibst du mir bitte die gibst du mir
zumindest mal die hälfte von den pfeilen
airlines alle haben ich glaube wirklich
keinen drachen ich kann von hier das
letzte ding treffen
ich habe es doch gerade zerstört das
allerletzte ja ich bin noch hoch
gegangen habe es zerstört der geht
deswegen geht ja doch noch auf uns ok
dann dann schaffen wir das jetzt wie
viel herz hast du
fast voll perfekt dann schaust du dass
du voll regeneriert naja wenn der typ
auf uns zu fliegt dann werde ich auf den
boxen und du kannst auch den schießen
aber behutsam mit den pfeilen ja also
wir gehen am anfang gehen wir am besten
mal okay wir haben schon richtig gezogen
leute das wird ja richtig das wird ja
richtig glaubst du wir schaffen das die
leute sollten in der letzten folge in
die kommentare schreiben and wenn wir
schaffen aber das sieht echt gut aus
die combo kleinern du kleiner bengel
okay er nimmt anlauf der flieger an uns
vorbei also er regeneriert echt nicht
mehr ich bewahre jetzt die pfeile für
die allerletzten schüsse auf ok er kommt
er kommt
ok hast du oder aloha heja am besten
beschließt schauen dass wir das wie ok
kommt wieder er kommt wieder marwin
haben angegeben bekämpft sehr gut altern
das spiel auf zeit
ja muss warten bis ein typ runterkommt
wie viel essen hast du noch
ich habe zwei mitgegeben sehr gut
eingebracht das habe vielleicht ich habe
auch nicht mehr so viel das ist das ist
dass das kriegen wir wirklich in max
glaube ich ich glaube das sind gut
hey das war der hammer wir müssen noch
miteinander bleiben max er kommt ja und
lukas springt so richtig rein hatte der
mutige retter kommt zu ändern
ich esse länder männern sie hatte ihn
einfach größer keine ahnung
der wird schon kommen dass ich angreifen
wir haben ihn fast auf die hälfte
gezogene usa denn er ist über uns jetzt
kommt da jetzt jetzt gegen ein hotel
errichtet mir richtig the match gewählt
werde ich brauche was zu essen
jedoch ist als einigermaßen in ordnung
aber wenn noch gebratenes fleisch
hättest der top-pick hier die perfekte
auge in auge sind immer gut mehr 64 hier
bitte natürlich
der ist vorne unterwegs agatha komplexer
jetzt klafft ein bisschen zusammenfassen
nochmal für uns ja genau
also es war für uns vor allem sowohl
relativ stressig weil wir es also an
einem tag aufgenommen haben als auch
wirklich wirklich cool also ich hätte
nicht gedacht dass es möglich ist noch
so viel spaß an minecraft zu haben
nachdem wir schon so lange gemacht haben
und das projekt insgesamt okay da kommt
er wieder war ein voller erfolg würde
ich sagen ja also ich kann das nur so
wiedergeben ihr habt das vielleicht
nicht so krass mitbekommen aber für uns
ist das ganze projekt ist halt wirklich
alles an einem tag aufgenommen es ist
gerade immer noch der nerd ist der 22
sogar wenn ihr die folge seht wir alle
nach 0 ist aber ich fahre morgen zum
beispiel ich fahre ich muss in neun
stunden am hauptbahnhof seine muss jetzt
noch die ganzen folgen schneiden und so
weiter und so fort das heißt ultra viel
arbeit wartet noch darauf
aber ich weiß nicht vielleicht hab ich
das projekt der gefallen und dann war da
ist auf jeden fall wert dann hätte sich
die arbeit gelohnt ja ok mit dem ball
schauen wie wir machen vielleicht habt
ihr in der beschreibung und zwar in
wasser wichtig dass wir halt in den uhr
in den urlauben sozusagen weil wir beide
im urlaub sind auch videos bringen
er kommt wieder kommt wieder das ist so
scheiße dass er sich nur einen hit geben
lässt
das ist aber ein richtiger bosheit das
dauert halt einfach luca wenn ihr grad
dabei sind was war denn deine lieblings
folge meine lieblings folge also meine
lieblingsstelle war auf jeden fall die
wo wir in meinem party diamanten
gefunden hatten
ja man meine lieblings folge ich weiß
nicht ich fand wir haben die 23
mitgegeben das perfekt meiner lieblings
folge l kann ich jetzt ich glaube sogar
die erste weil das so komplett
bescheuert war einfach das schild das
wäre jetzt herum geschrieben haben und
so dieser periode besser dass es nicht
nur einen mitgeben lässt es ist echt
krass
dann müssen wir vielleicht ein bisschen
damit arbeiten dass wir ihn auf einen
von uns polen vor krass ey ist schon
fast tot es schon fast der hammer ja
deswegen das habe ich ja gesagt ist ich
finde es ende auch eigentlich recht easy
ehrlich gesagt wenn wir jetzt noch
sterben dann musst du irgendwann
irgendwas machen wir jetzt noch sterben
dann machen wir noch ein paar weiter
da machen wir machen staffel sonst
vielleicht wie wollt ihr eine zweite
staffel leute dann schreibt man die
kommentare maut wenn ihr noch eine
zweite staffel haben wollte dann
wirklich mit peg er kommt ja meine maus
und spart gerade total rom wo sie hinten
gerade eben hatte ist er über uns her
geflogen wie kriegen wir ein ende machen
stark besserer live hast du schon einmal
geändert drachen besiegt in minecraft
damit mit gomez schon in ein zwei
projekten okay mal kommt erst mal
relativ lang abspannen und man kriegt
halt unendlich viel erfahrung blockiert
ich level oder so in das ist gut wird
sagen die erfahrungen wir uns dann
einfach wenn wir microsofts diesen zwei
aufnehmen ja man so allmählich ich habe
ja noch fünf eile aber ich glaub ich
spare mir die wirklich für das ende auf
also wenn es wenn es richtig eng wird
mache ich das richtig eng jetzt zum
beispiel ein zwei hits oder so ok ok
kommt wieder her kommt wieder und ich
jetzt sterben noch durch die ender mend
das wäre es okay ich habe ein gekipptes
macht max 28 und baute ich eindeutig ein
oder so ich beschütze ich glaube wir
haben alle tot
ok dann ab ins portal leute bevor wir
springen wir haben es geschafft wir
haben den ärger machen musik luca wir
haben es wirklich geschafft also gut wir
haben uns halt zum end geschieht das
hätte zu lange gedauert es zu finden
aber wir beide haben es geschafft
innerhalb von zehn folgen ein haus zu
bauen uns auszurüsten den ende drachen
zu besiegen in netter zu gehen alles ist
der hammer ok luca ist kraft vielleicht
schaffen dass manchen schon in der
ersten folge aber wir sind max und luca
wir sind nicht die allerbesten von da
würde ich sagen springen bei 33 23 leute
das war es war eine schöne zeit ich
hoffe euch hat es genau so sehr gefallen
wie uns und dann freue ich mich bei den
nächsten videos wieder begrüßen zu
dürfen luca hast du noch irgendwelche
worte kauf beim merchandise wertvoll
okay leute hier findet ihr den
abonnieren -button falls ihr noch nicht
genug von meinem kanal bekommen habt und
hier gibt es noch ein weiteres video da
würde ich sagen wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder danke fürs zu sehen
und wir verabschieden uns